another really important thing I think
people should know is that between 1950
and
2010 the rate of welfare spending in
both the UK and the United States has
gone up at the same exact rate as out of
wedlock births isn't that interesting
wow so the more out of wedlock births we
have our welfare spending goes up and if
you look at the two plotted out on a
graph they go up like this just in
perfect lock step with one another so I
mean we have a lot of good statistics a
lot of good data a lot of good math that
can't really be argued with that shows
that the more we encourage women that
they must focus on Career the harder it
becomes for them to even look at
motherhood as an option do you know what
I mean